hi there I'm will Dana measuring at our
rolling stone and it's my great pleasure
to introduce Matt Taibbi who I was going
to say is my favorite political writer
but i think was really one of my
favorite writers period we I first met I
didn't make I first knew him at about
nineteen ninety-eight when we sent a
reporter to Russia to write about so
young Americans who were living in
Moscow at the height of the sort of
decadent money fueled culture of the new
Russia and it didn't take him long to
find that the best story there was on
this newspaper called the exile which
matt and his friend mark Ames had
started and were editing and were doing
an incredible job of pissing off many
many people in Russia and America and uh
you know the X file was raw and funny
and pointed and every issue was full of
these sort of I can't believe they just
wrote that kind of stuff and so we kept
our eye on that and in a couple years
later it came back to New York and then
I'd seen him writing stuff in the nation
and various other magazines and I got in
touch with him and I had this idea first
of sending him out on the on the
campaign trail when he did a piece for
us in which he was in the campaign on
the on the kerry campaign plane the
highlight of which was he took a bunch
of asset and dressed up in a Viking
costume who knows really why you can
explain that to us later cuz uh but it
was more than a stunt because it really
was a way of Matt I mean in Matt I think
what you see in Matt's writing is it's
not as funny and angry and he's
completely exposing himself and if he's
making fun of the process and making fun
of the people there he's in some ways
saving his harshest and really turning
the guns on himself in a way that makes
it instantly human and um
you know and sad sad exactly but sad
funny crying on the inside kind of so
anyways then the next thing we did is we
sent Matt undercover in a were in the
Republican the Bush campaign office in
Orlando Florida last year where he
concocted this ridiculous cover story
about how he was a new york city school
teacher stuck in orlando for the summer
following his girlfriend who was what
was she doing in orlando she was from
there she was from there and so Matt
just sort of showed up at this sort of
rather pathetic little Bush campaign
headquarters and proceeded to become the
best volunteer they had ever seen ended
up managing one of the offices in
Orlando so ended up managing the office
you know rotate a great piece which
ended up getting us sued by a deputy
campaign manager who no no no no a Tampa
sheriff's deputy who had some wild ideas
about wanting to create clone armies to
get rid of all the minorities and drug
dealers yeah actually the basis of that
suit was really funny right here this
guy was a volunteer for the Bush
campaign and basically what I was doing
is I was taking notes anytime anybody
came into the office and I just compiled
at the end some of the funnier scenes
from from my experience working for the
Bush campaign and this guy was this
really portly sheriff's deputy and he
came in with this whole plan about how
the war in Iraq would be so much easier
if we had clones fighting for us instead
of instead of real soldiers because if
they got injured we could just shoot
them and all this stuff so I wrote I
read all this stuff down and and you
know included some descriptions about
what this guy looked like and it was you
know he was not an impressive looking
guy so and he I ended up getting picked
on by but people at his office right
right yeah the basis of this well he
first wanted to tell us that he was
gonna lose his job over what Matt wrote
but that quickly I guess you can't fire
a sheriff's Fe that easily in Tampa
right so even though he had already been
caught once for sleeping on the job and
it right
he's managing a jail cell so the the
base the lawsuit became that we hurt his
feelings right yeah he wanted well first
he was gonna first he offered to settle
for ten thousand dollars and then we
when we reach you to that he asked for
over a hundred right and then the the
judge down a Florida last the lawsuit
and threw it out but he sent this as an
exhibit it was really funny I guess his
co-workers at the Tampa Sheriff's Office
made up a mock up of rolling stone with
him on the cover and the headline was
what Tampa's fetish eres exactly that
was the I was Exhibit A that he had been
picked on it works yes but um what so
that's how that work so Matt was there
for two I mean he I mean we made him
waste two of his months to two months of
his life um it was his ridiculous
charade but he really wrote a piece
which i think you know got at some dark
and ineffable truth about the Bush
campaign and you know beneath all of the
humor and the making fun of stuff and
you know the the gonzo theatrics of it
was you know a really impassioned story
about you know about the peeping out of
that sort of how the Bush campaign was
you know turning on its followers and
seducing these people with this angry
rhetoric and with these completely
unrealistic dreams and you know it was
sort of using them and uh and of course
Matt was using them for humor but but
you know it was really a way of you know
shows I think Matt's his dedication and
his willingness to do anything to get
through away from my personal life away
from his personal life which we'll talk
about later and just to show their the
rhetoric and to show how these campaigns
really work in the show you know that we
see these you know this image of the
Bush campaign is this unstoppable
juggernaut you know rolling across
America which is doing but also at the
same time you know it was this
rinky-dink operation with with no real
command and control with no one really
knowing what they were doing right right
um you could just walk off the street
and uh you know and literally be in
charge in a major you know important
electoral battle ground within a week
was was kind of an interesting sidelight
to that story but I wanted to ask matt a
little bit because you know he did spend
ten years in Russia reporting on you
know sort of feet in a society you know
in an incredible freefallin change and I
just want to have that talk about his
experiences you know working in his
paper in Russia the kind of stories he
was writing there how he felt about
covering Russia as an outsider and the
society there then coming home and
writing about his own his own culture
and you know as he points out interested
this book is that in Russia he could
just be an outsider and he could he
could write about this from a distance
and know that it wasn't you know that he
was not implicated in any way whereas
when he came to the US he was writing
about his home he was writing about the
culture and the world that created him
and he was coming at it as someone as he
says a northeastern liberal you know
child of privilege looking at this thing
from you know from his privileged
position and I wonder like you know what
did you see is the difference and how
did you know how was a journalist did
you approach his two different stories
yeah I mean uh I guess being on Russia
one of the things that's so great about
Russia is that it's so open and there's
such an incredible for a journalist is
such an immense opportunity just to do
almost any kind of story you want just
by talking your way into the middle of
something pretty much the whole time I
was there any story that I was doing my
strategy would just be to just get into
the middle of it and for instance said
there was a minor crisis were in 1998
where miners were striking all over the
country and they were basically holding
up train traffic and really grinding the
whole economy to his stand still and and
so what I was able to do with that story
we just go to one of these towns and
just work as a minor I mean I just
walked into the into the office instead
I'd like to be a miner for a week and
see what that's like you know see how
these guys actually live or you know we
did a story about education in Moscow I
know I did like the Fast Times at
Ridgemont High thing and what became a
high school student for a couple of
weeks or there was a story in what it's
really all over Russia where people are
essentially indentured servants
they don't get paid for the labor they
do so if you're a really hard labor you
just get kits for the company commissary
and that's what you're expected to live
on so what I wanted to do that story I
went to Siberia and I worked as a
bricklayer in a construction site for a
couple of weeks you know again just to
see how these people really live and
even with something like corruption you
know it at the federal level in Russia
there's so many more things you can do
that you can't do here in the states I
mean when we and just before I left one
of the things that I did was we hired an
annex KGB general to Commission the
wiretapping with the Kremlin and had
basically wiretap the Kremlin chief of
staff for two weeks and then ran a full
transcript of everything that he said he
talked about and it was all about you
know trading influence for this or that
and all kinds of incredibly illegal
stuff that came out on the tape and we
just published it and you expect it to
be arrested at any minute but never was
you know why was that because you were
writing English in a small circulation
paper in Moscow oh I actually published
that in Russian first oh you did yeah
and but the thing is Russians are so
ignored to that kind of stuff that
because I corruption right exactly you
can you can publish that the the
president personally murdered a child on
you know in front of a crowd of 100
people and and that really wouldn't
really wouldn't do a whole lot so you
know so coming back to the States after
why details we're gone at the end didn't
you also create a very exciting job
opportunity for a Mikhail Gorbachev when
you were there yeah yeah one of the
things that that we did we first started
the newspaper the Exile we were really
looking for a publicity stunt to try to
bring bring a publicity to this new
publication that we had so we I
pretended to be representative for the
New York Jets and approach Gorbachev's
office and said you know you know you
were so great at that whole
restructuring thing you know rebuilding
that's what perestroika means and you
know we've got a football team that's
really in a rebuilding phase right now
and so we could really use your help and
we offered him 150 thousand dollars to
give pep talks to the team before each
game and and we just we thought they
would laugh at us but next thing you
know we got this letter over our fax
machine saying the president's willing
to sign the deal immediately in flat in
New York and all this stuff so but again
this is something you just couldn't
possibly get away with in America is
like most most of the stuff that we were
doing just that Russia was such virgin
territory for that kind of thing that it
was really easy to pull these kinds of
pranks and and stuff like that why can't
you do that here I guess he could but
they were a lot more sophisticated on to
him and Russia you know five years
before I did something like that if a
journalist had pulled something like
that you know he'd be he'd be breaking
rocks for the rest of his life in the
best-case scenario so they they they
don't really expect that kind of thing
they do now but you know at the time i
was there really wasn't like that now
when you went out on the campaign trail
last year did me or two years ago now
did you did you expect that you would be
able to create new I mean you were going
the press Caravan you were in the back
of the planes you know with all the new
york times in Boston Globe reporters
being fed the press releases by the by
that each candidate's press secretary
and like did you go out there thinking
okay like I'm gonna be able to write the
truth here I'm gonna be able to break
news or do I just I thought it would
find something you know I mean let you
know normally you figure if you're if
you're a good writer and you get stuck
in the middle of a really interesting
situation you should be able to come up
with something but what I think was you
know most of what this book is about is
like being on the campaign trail really
really precludes almost anything
interesting coming out of it if your
ears we decided you know basically the
last two presidential campaigns that it
really wasn't worth having reporter on
the plains and you know with the
campaign's anymore because so little
happened and there was so little ability
for anyone to write anything interesting
we r you know unless you had someone
willing to come in there and basically
flout all the rules and they can ask
themselves because you know I think one
thing that happens in Matt writes about
a lot is that the press sort of conforms
to what's expected of them by the people
by the campaigns and it becomes this
weirdly mutualistic exercise and sort of
nothingness in futility right because
you know the reporters are just sitting
there what you know waiting till five
o'clock
to file their stories and just you know
write about whatever little teeny tidbit
of nothing the candidate talks about
that day right yeah and you know and the
reporter is also being in that situation
that they really enforce if you're if
you don't do that if you're not there
for that particular thing they don't
like that and they really enforce this
kind of high school hierarchy where
where you're suddenly frozen out if
you're not if you're not acting in the
way that they like and in fact you know
I had that happen to me literally from
the first day I was on the campaign
trail I I went from being you know a new
kid to being the uncoolest you know
pariah on the campaign trail within the
space for 24 hours and what did you do
to earn that title it's actually really
it's really funny that the whole
chronology the first date was so funny
because I showed up you know completely
wet behind the ears had never been on I
mean I done a couple of things I've been
on a Dean Dean's plane in the summer
before but I'd never been on a major
presidential frontrunner Twain you know
in the middle of a campaign and I plus I
hadn't really been in America for very
long so it was all very new for me so I
showed up and I had a little video
camera with me and this is just for my
own personal you know recollection I
wanted to kind of keep a diary of what I
was doing and and just you know so I
could look at look at it later or show
to my grandkids someday so I'm literally
the first moment I show up in the
campaign trail is in Washington i joined
carry and i'm carrying around my video
camera and i'm just talking to myself as
i'm walking around and as i take my
first steps onto the bus I'm saying okay
this is great here i am officially a boy
on the bus now you know etc etc and the
next step that I took I got stopped by
Pat Healy of the Boston Globe and Jill's
document in Chicago Tribune and they're
like turn that [ __ ] off that was the
first thing they said oh like what so
you can't film the reporters and I'm
like you know first of all you know it's
not for publication it's just for me and
second of all you know says who and
they're like what we say you know that's
that's the rule in the plane so so that
was the first thing that happened I put
the camera away little did I know that
or after that suck Minh and Kili were on
the phone to how it Kurtz the Washington
Post telling on me for filming the other
journalists and a story that would come
out three weeks later that I was served
ish ously spying on all the all the
journalists so I was instantly on his
behalf on your behalf apparently yeah
you know and you know this was this is
again this is the first moments in the
plan that they didn't have a chance to
ask me who I was what I was doing there
or anything like that so that happens
then I get onto the plane if everybody's
gonna remember this whole story but
Carrie having a mistress then remember
this one that service on the drudge
report that Carrie had was sleeping with
one of his interns right yeah so this
thing this thing had just broken that
morning Drudge would put this thing out
that morning so the whole plane is
buzzing about it cuz they're all
thinking this is the beginning of the
next Lewinsky story right so they want
to be in on it just as a side note this
is kind of another interesting
phenomenon that happened with campaign
journalism in the last work just any
political journalism in the last few
years you know it used to be that you
had to check a story out and make sure
that was true before you wrote about it
but now it is with them when the blog's
put something out there it's already a
thing and the journalists think they can
just write about it anyway even though
it's might be completely unsubstantiated
or there might not be any facts behind
it the Carrie mistress thing was one
example another good one was remember
the transmitter the Bush allegedly had
on his back during the debates that that
was originally brought up in a website
called bushes wired.com anybody remember
this and it was basically some clown
well we was in a clown i don't know but
hit but he he you know she had showed
some diagram of some CIA device right
that he had dug up that was you know
apparently the thing that was in bushes
bushes suit and next thing you know it's
the front page story that Elizabeth
Boone Miller in the in the New York
Times is writing about and she's writing
about it as a as a news phenomenon right
you know not like if they have facts but
the phenomenon of this blog report so
it's like this end around you know
around the usual journalistic practice
of making sure that something's checked
out
so anyways they're all buzzing about it
about this unsubstantiated story that
Matt drudges running and like everybody
else I want to I want to get to carry
and hear what he has to say about it and
I pick up my stuff I'm in like the fifth
row of the press section of the plane
and Kari comes back to give us to say
hello to the press and I'm about to get
into the the corridor and Cheryl gay
Stolberg the New York Times reporter
literally decks me not not to me like
completely out and she's a little tiny
person she knocked me into the into the
aisle and to back into my seats my stuff
goes flying I look up and Perry bacon
the time magazine reporter holds up a
little piece of paper on any rights on
it nytimes you know like saying I see
you get it like they get to go up fret
you know so so that happens so they they
start writing about it everybody's
following this mistress thing and I and
I heard Maria laganja the LA Times
reporter she's on the phone and she's
verbally filing a story about it like a
couple of hours after it happens so I'm
just curious and I go through with a
notebook and I say I'm doing a story
about the campaign I'm just curious you
know why it is you're deciding to cover
this given that you know it's
unsubstantiated etc etc and she's like
are you asking me this on the record you
know and I said well yeah she's like
she's like I'm not going to talk to you
in the record are you crazy we don't do
that so so I did that happened a couple
of times we went around to a bunch of
reporters and i was told that nobody
would talk to me about why they were
we're not covering don't you think that
the reporter every report on that plane
is equally a cynical and as aware of the
process of what's going on as you are
but no one but no one wants to actually
say because they're playing the game
yeah well they mean you just you know
it's a story right if Kerry has a
mistress they have to do something but
they're not but at that point there an
absolutely no position to find out the
truth about it because they're starting
their own immune clevelander Cincinnati
or st. Louis yeah they're not making
that call their editors in making that
call so but they know they have to chase
down the response on it anyway
so it's a very uncomfortable situation
for them but I mean the point is they're
stuck there you know supposedly on the
biggest story of the of the day but
really in a position to do nothing more
but chase beyond irrelevant scraps right
right exactly you know and they sort of
know that deep down I think but the same
time they're telling themselves look
where I am and I'm covering the campaign
right exactly they all feel like they're
you know especially on the campaign
there's like this there's a hierarchy
about where you get to sit like the cool
kids sit at the front of the plane and
the loser sit in the very back of the
plane and they they all take their
positions in the plane very seriously
who gets to be cool and who doesn't get
to be cool so even though you know even
though that's not a legit really a
legitimate story they have to act like
they're really important people all the
time but in any case the whole point
being the end of the story just to rush
quickly is that is that after word got
around that I had been asking the other
reporters questions on the record the
next morning in las vegas i went to get
on the plane and I found that I had been
reassigned to sit in the very last seat
with all the techies in the plane and so
I was I was literally in a seat and
there's like camera equipment piled on
either side of me and you know the kerry
campaign aide who clearly had been
talked to by somebody came back to me
and he's like so is everything ok are
you comfortable back here you know did
you ever get a moment with carrie no i
never got him on what we always had
promised that or you know uh you know I
talked to him and I you know I would ask
routinely like if I could have a moment
with Carrie and I would always say no
but what was really interesting about
about the the kind of response I got
from carries aids was if I asked them a
completely ridiculous question they were
quick to come back with an answer for me
from the candidate but if I'd like what
well I love them anything let me give
you this example the serious one first I
asked once I I asked David Morehouse who
was carries a chief aide on the plane I
said you know why isn't Carrie talking
about Vietnam the same way that he
talked about it when he came back from
Vietnam
he never offers an opinion about the war
anymore does he still have the same
opinions etc etc etc he's like I'll get
back to you and every time I ask a
question like that it was the same thing
I would never get the answer but when I
asked what position did Carrie play when
you played hockey in high school you
know right away Carrie was a defenseman
he was probably the second best player
in the team and incidentally he got a
hat-trick when he played soccer against
harvard and when he was at Yale so like
that was the kind of thing that was the
way this works and so what other
reporters be like oh he's said he's in
said that to anybody like you know you
should be really happy with it with that
little bit that you got oh yeah totally
I mean a great example of that is when
you know Kerry had this routine every
morning where he would um he would come
on the tarmac and one of his aides would
take out some kind of sporting item was
either baseball and a couple of gloves
or football at the period that we were
dealing with from it was more of the
winter so he was more in his football
mode and he would come out every morning
and he would play catch with one of his
aides and instantly all his aides could
never catch the ball it was really
twenties it I always got the sense that
they chose these guys specifically
because they look they're worse applets
and Kerry was so he would be throwing
the ball to these guys and the press
every morning even though they'd seen
exactly the same shot every day they
would bound out of the plane the instant
Kerry took the football out and they
would rush out to the tarmac and they
would there would be a pool a swarm of
photographers right around carry as he
was catching and releasing the ball so
you couldn't even see the candidate he
would be like behind this whole army of
photographers throwing this football
anyway I was the first reporter on the
plane they can to think about playing
the game with Kerry you know a guy well
everybody else is taking the picture I'm
not like well let's see what kind of arm
carrie has you know so I I broke out
from the pack and he'll like you know
hit me I'm going deep throws me the
football I threw it back I got on the
plane everyone's like that's so cool you
know he threw the ball you know
but that's that's the kind of mentality
they had they were like you know they're
really excited for you when you got
something like that you know but but
yeah and then being being stuck in the
in the in the campaign itself it's like
a one of the things I started to notice
after a while is how completely isolated
and insular the whole atmosphere is and
this is something that people don't they
don't realize when they're looking at
the campaign from the outside what a
bizarre environment it is for the
journalists I don't you think the
journals realize that because they're so
in it that they don't see it either do
that yeah yeah it's really funny they
most of them don't see a few of them
think about it from time to time but for
the most part they don't I mean it's so
isolated that that if you smoke in the
campaign you don't have time to get
cigarettes for yourself there's never a
time when you're actually free of the
campaign long enough to go outside the
parameters of the campaign to go to a
store or talk to a normal human being
now this you know this ought to trigger
some kind of question in your mind if
your journalism am I actually seeing any
real people you know when I when I
travel around the country literally
thousands of miles a day and you're
never outside the boundaries of this
self contained environment is basically
the plane and the event so you go from
the plane to the bus to the event we are
we're roped off literally roped off from
the public I mean you get to talk to the
people who are inside the event but once
it's the front-runner you have these
secret service tags if you don't get
into the event in the beginning you
can't get back into it until it's over
so nobody leaves the event once it
starts so it's it's literally like a
prison I mean you go from from event to
event and the only time you're ever free
is when you get back to the hotel which
is always at 12 or 1230 at night and you
have to be on the road again by five in
the morning so it's it's it's really not
a whole lot different from work release
in prison except that it's a five-star
hotel and you get fed catered meals six
or seven times a day so it's really
strange but um and even beyond that you
know you're talking about do the people
realize it or not
no not only is it contained but they
actually have people pointing you in the
direction you have to go in all the time
and if there aren't physically human
beings pointing you in the in the in the
direction where the press has to go
there are arrows on the floor I mean
they must have used up probably a
hundred thousand arrows in the in the
kerry campaign you would get out you'd
get the bus and there be orange arrows
on the ground leading literally leaving
you to your seat in the filing room
Arlo's moveon.org I donations paid for
exactly what I remember I talked to the
this Boston Globe photographer once and
he's like yeah you know it's funny the
first couple of days you're on you're
like why are they treating me like a
[ __ ] you know and then a month later
you're like where the arrows just really
funny now one of the things you did in
the last chapter in the book is that
you've conducted the wimble hack
tournament right you know during the
campaign last fall in which you did Oh
an elimination round every week you
eliminated one reporter until someone
had emerged as the greatest hack on the
campaign right now these are the people
I mean you were off the trail by then
right right but what kind of response
did you get from the people that you
were writing about there well I got a
one guy from God I forget who it was is
it some guy from the New York Times
actually offered to fight me because I
had described Jody will gore and is
looking like Ernest Borgnine and he's
like how would you like it if somebody
wrote that about you and I kind of look
like Ernest Borgnine he's like next time
I see you you were gonna be stepping
outside I'm like all right whatever but
the funny thing is though that most of
the angry letters I got again we're from
the front of the plane people whereas
the back of the plane people were like
yeah [ __ ] kill him you know so I got
a I got a lot of letters from from
people that I've been in the trill if
who kind of felt the same way because it
really is a you know class system with
it within the within the campaign but I
noticed oh you had some people almost
sort of you know like didn't you tell me
that Karen Tumulty from time would sort
of write you these these self-effacing
deprecating emails about what you're
writing about her oh yeah kick it like
they were clearly all journalists or
general because they're right for living
there very vain I mean they pay
attention to what what's being written
about them so Karen Tumulty again I said
something really nasty about her i said
i think i said something like that she
was uh she looked like a pre-op version
of Dave Barry as I said and and she she
wrote me this letter you know saying
that I was a hack and a nobody and it's
etcetera etcetera and then the next
thing I know she doesn't want to advance
in the tournament so she's like she's
like well what can I you know if I do
this and this will I get out of the
tournament next week or you know maybe
you know clearly here she wanted to to
try to try to say something nice to me
you know just just just to try to keep
keep out of the tournament but did you
feel bad writing these things I mean
you're a nice guy and you're very
friendly and yet you would write these
vicious things about these people
journalists aren't people okay yourself
included yeah myself included i don't
know i mean it I you know I do i do
obviously feel feel bad but I think you
know if there's anything that I that any
tangible benefits of doing the kind of
stuff that I do I guess is to you know
it might have some kind of prophylactic
effect I mean it's not like I was just
at making ad hominem attacks against
people it was pointing out you know the
kinds of things that they were doing
that were you know either shady or lazy
or whatever I was trying to make a
serious point about their journalism and
then pick on them a little bit and if
people you know felt like it was less if
they made admit their job seemed like it
was less cool maybe they would you know
do it differently so you know it wasn't
like I was just picking on people for no
reason now what do you think is the
alternative to covering these campaigns
I mean that that's probably a wrestle
with is you know it's like you're either
you know it's either on the plane you're
not on the plane and once you're on the
plane nothing's happening right you know
I mean should the should these things be
covered on a day-to-day basis like this
well see I you know again I think I
think what's really interesting about
the campaign is that it's just it's the
problem really isn't the way that you've
covered the story of being on the plane
it's a point of view issue where I think
these journalists again they fly all
around the country and all they see is
the candidates
theoretically this should be a time when
we're really looking at America's
problems and and really looking closely
at the country and having a political
discussion but we don't do that because
because the journalists were all looking
squarely at the candidates if we were
looking at the country and trying to
broadcast what was going on in America
to the candidates as opposed to doing it
the other way around we're broadcasting
the candidates to the country maybe
things but nothing you point out is
there is this relentless focus on the
horse race right you know every day and
the strategy in the poll numbers as if
you know and that becomes covered as the
story which I mean it is a story
obviously because it's interesting but
at the same time like that is you know
in the political press it's like that is
treated as the only thing that's to be
talked about right yeah I mean who's
winning and who isn't winning but you
mean you know that that's that's
basically the way it works in the best
finish how else would you cover it right
Al's but if you're stuck on the plane I
mean that's really all you have to write
about right exactly I mean it's like
they they the people who to would have
figured this was a brilliant way to keep
the you know to keep the media for
talking about the issues right is it to
keep them all following the candidates
all the time you know um you know one of
the things that I tried to do is try to
try to get away from that is a or just
to show how ridiculous it was when I
would get to a campaign site i would i
would leave immediately and run a mile
in any direction and it would find like
a bad neighborhood because the campaigns
were always in a good neighborhood i saw
this really funny line once I I asked
one of Carey's people I said why is that
the campaign never visits ghetto you
know because again this is something
that it's all about image for the
candidates that they want to be seen in
circumstances that make them look good
so you'll never see almost never see a
candidate around poor people in bad
neighborhoods in situations where he
doesn't look like it's the middle of a
Norman Rockwell painting so that they
ask this guy welcome you never do that
and he says well that's not true we went
to Harlem once you know that was his
answer and he had actually gone to I
think it was the Apollo Theater is where
anywhere
too but anyway was to try to get around
that I would get to a site and I would
run to the bad neighborhood and I would
ask you know then what they fill out
about the candidates and then I would
have just enough time to get back to the
campaign site to get back on the plane
and so for the last probably week and a
half that I was Eve on the carry plane I
didn't even see the candidate probably
you know but won't you also some treat
you know it was this was probably seen
as a very irresponsible thing to do
wasn't it like what does this guy think
he's doing yeah yeah the other
journalists definitely didn't like that
they were there were local what are you
doing although some people said that
that was an interesting idea but you
know they obviously because I work work
for a magazine that allowed allowed me
to do something a little bit unusual i
was i was able to do that but these guys
if you work for a pee or something you
can't you can't just you know bugger off
in the middle of an event and go go talk
to a poor person that's not going to
work so that's interesting but but ya
know what else um so I mean
and that Rick tell us a little bit what
you're doing right now you've been
covering the michael jackson trial right
yeah yeah we're saying that back out
there but um get away I mean he seems in
some ways as weird almost continuation
of the campaign of you know this other
media story which we focus on yeah
actually it's almost an identical
situation that's like you know it's this
completely self-contained media circus
right in the middle of middle of the of
Santa Maria Kelly California and the the
the trial has been again because it when
you get to the courthouse in Santa Maria
it's like they've erected ad hoc towers
all around the courthouse they've you
know there's there's 1700 accredited
media personnel adjust for this one
court case and but has the case has no
interest for the at the outside public
in in on the courthouse they have a lawn
bowling green where the elderly and the
Santa Maria community play leg plate
lawn bowling and those lawn bowling
games every day have been out drawing
the trial by a factor of about two to
one each day so again it's like it's a
real it's kind of a funny funny story
about how there's so much media
attention directed at one thing but the
actual public doesn't care at all which
is kind of the same thing as the
campaign what I think what you've had in
your coverage so far of Jackson is um I
mean you're actually paying attention
and listening to what these people are
saying in court every day and you know
it's like this you know it's like a
Fyodor Dreiser novel and if you're
incredible detail about American life
and these people and you know that gets
overlooked completely you know in this
Court race a horse race or did he do it
did he not do it yeah right exactly is
it you'll do you know that seems almost
irrelevant to the proceedings right you
know and this incredible you know this
just it's like the most bizarre story
you know that that it you know out there
right now right and it's really sad in a
way instead of tragic but for completely
different reasons it's a you know but
again it's like it's the same phenomenon
that's the reason for that though I mean
like with this cable news cycle and
everything year you have to have if you
have to file five or six times a day the
only the only that you have to be able
to have a story that has a
anibal running plotline that you can
come back to over and over and over
again and that's really it the
logistical you know foundation for the
story is the most important thing is the
same thing with the campaign who's
winning who's losing you know that's
going to be a story tomorrow you know
it's going to be the story the next day
so that's what you plan around I mean it
seems to be the funny thing is everyone
is talk you know is wringing their hands
over you know the revelant of the major
media and the declining newspaper
circulation and the declining ratings on
CNN and Fox right and it's like they
aren't the thing aren't looking at is
well they're giving us you know the
thing of the diet of a thinnest gruel
possible right you know and giving us
this you know offering so little insight
into these stories right you know and
making about personality making about
the newscasters and not making about
what they're putting of what they're
putting on right and you know it it
seems that you know the biggest question
is not being asked right which is you
know maybe people don't want to watch
this maybe this is not enough there I
CNN 22 want to tune into it right in
fact they don't want to watch it the
ratings you know for Michael Jackson
have been abysmal they would like barely
barely registering a blip in this
country anyway well so does not
televised resonator is entitled out and
I think that goes back to the campaign
where you know it's like the way the
campaign is covered seems to you know
they leach out all the content you know
and give it this fake content of the
horse race right whereas to really ask
the bigger questions you know which they
came out a little bit more this year
right but at the same time you know it's
amazing how stupefying and numb so much
of the coverage is right and it appeals
to such a small plaque you know the
political class right and makes the you
know the obsessions of the political
consultants become you know what
everyone America's supposed to care
about right right and what the end the
obsessions of the journalists themselves
is supposed to be whatever America
everybody America cares about so you
never get anything about what the issues
are actually about so the content has
completely sucked out of the process do
you want to read from that bit about
your experience in New Orleans and then
p.m.
read this and then we can open up to
questions from the audience here put you
out of your misery so this is um again
some almost like just to give some
background I'm stuck in this in this
campaign and I'm really will is like
breathing down my neck all the time
about what I have and I have nothing you
know so and I don't want to tell him
this and one of the things i'd noticed
and the campaign is they feed you like
six times a day there were literally
gigantic catered spreads like no i don't
read you a list in a second but they
wouldn't feed us you know three times a
day like in our own person was literally
six full meals a day and I and I was so
deranged from stress and from from
worrying about how to cover the story
that that it suddenly seemed to me like
the most important thing about about the
whole campaign was the food and and I
decided that I was going to try to
reject the story by not eating so I went
on this hunger strike and and so I at
the time this starts I hadn't eaten for
five days so and I'm and I'm going crazy
about trying to figure out how to how to
how to cover the stories this is in this
is in New Orleans the spread of the
filing Center in New Orleans was about
par for the course massive and scale
with a local flavor so you know where
you are there was boiled crawfish
crawfish etouffee red beans and rice
with sausage ratatouille braised catfish
bread pudding and rolls with parsley
butter praline cookies fresh brewed iced
tea the speech that day was to contain
an escalation of anti-bush rhetoric
something about the president's foreign
policy being really reckless and
irresponsible the food looked great but
I wasn't having any I'd stop eating from
the campaign trough three days before in
fact I'd stopped going to events all
together previously it had been an
occasional thing but now is an official
policy rather than stay in the
high-class neighborhood where the events
were always held and made it a point to
seek out the bad neighborhood full of
non-voters that was always precisely a
half mile away and personally delivered
the message that I didn't give a [ __ ]
about their lives
in New Orleans carry speech the coin
flip produced a rally not a town-hall
incidentally that's the two kinds of
events that he had was held outside at
the seaport in the heart of the Latin
Quarter walking outside walking out of
the area straight down Connie Street you
have to pass through about five blocks
of tourist shops full of plastic voodoo
skeleton souvenirs rubber masks and
aprons bearing messages like New Orleans
don't [ __ ] with the chef then the shops
melt away into bars and daiquiri stands
and from there the bars turned into
warehouses and finally you pass by a
French cemetery and just behind the
winn-dixie is a stark dirt lot full of
low low rise brick buildings this used
to be Storyville the birthplace of jazz
one time home to jelly roll morton and
Louis Armstrong but now it's the
Iberville housing projects this place is
so rough that it wasn't there two
minutes before a kindly black police
woman named Sharon cager zoomed up in
her cruiser are you lost she said no I
said flashing my tags impressed she
looked at me as though smelling rotting
cheese what the hell are you doing here
I'm covering the presidential election I
said and she took about 20 seconds to
think about that yeah right she said and
you know where you are the projects
right she shook her head you're gonna
get jacked up in here she said she drove
off I started going door to door as was
usually the case it took a while before
I found anyone who planned on voting in
the next election the approval rating of
politicians in places like this hover
somewhere between Stalin and athlete's
foot I don't like to use the word hate
hate is a bad word but sometimes that's
how I feel about them I don't believe a
word they say said let the agree shard a
six year old woman and longtime resident
of iberville a stray dog deserves better
than what we've got look what we have to
work with there used to be a bleach
factory right behind here a lot of the
folks in this neighborhood got real sick
there'd be sludge from the factory
running into the street and the kids
would have to walk through it just to
get the school then there was a fire
there we were lucky the wind was blowing
the other way that day we tried to get
them to do something about safety but
every time I went to a City Hall they
just send out a different person that
told me they were busy
now they're gonna close this place up
and we're all going to be moved
somewhere else she said as it is we get
subsidized utilities but the next place
that's not going to happen they tell us
I can't even find out what's going on
our Councilwoman Jackie Clarkson she's a
Democrat she's the mother Patricia
Clarkson you know the actress I keep
going to her office but like I said
every time I do they send out someone
else to tell me to go away I mean she
represents the quarter to so who are we
like I said the stray dog deserves
excuse me I said looking at my watch I
hate to interrupt but I've got to go
what she said look this is all very
interesting i said but i'm working you
understand and i have to get back right
away I might miss John Kerry playing
frisbee she's staring in shock playing
what actually he prefers football I said
and he's pretty good at it you should
see it he throws a really nice ball she
nodded oh ok well nice talking to you
take care back at the seaport the event
had broken up in a large contingent of
the campaign staff had gone exploring
ending up on Bourbon Street where they
bought large quantities of Mardi Gras
beads and king sized hurricane cocktails
there was a lot of laughing and
stumbling around and there was one
reporter I wish I'd got in the picture
who was wearing what appeared to be his
weight and beads and standing in perfect
contentment with his lip stain bright
red from drink the party continued on
the plane were carry himself even got
into the action tiptoeing into the press
kit press area to catch some beads do I
have to flash for the easy said show us
your health plan someone shouted
everyone laughed well it starts with 12
steps care equipped drunken conversation
overheard in the bus that night in and
Houston it's too bad we didn't stay
behind in New Orleans yeah we know New
Orleans we know it too well anyway
that's it well at this point we should
throw up in the questions from out there
so that the cameras can pick up your
your question thank you
um what's up uh was the sort of group
think that you're talking about the
Samantha group stink sounds almost
unbelievable like was there really no no
one else who is dissenting or calling it
all into a question among the the pool I
mean there were some times that people
would talk about it amongst themselves a
little bit but you have to remember that
there's there's no way to really get an
alternative type of journalists in the
plane because it costs so much I mean
you're not going to get somebody from
alternate or you know some other kind of
publication because it costs probably
about twenty five hundred dollars a day
to send you on the campaign trail so I
mean for the most part the people who
were on that plane were aware of a
certain type and they were perfectly
happy with what the way things were
going hi um first off what what is your
sense of why the press was so
antagonistic to anyone writing about the
press in which and in the main papers
they would you know have a pressed memo
or something which would be a kind of
analysis of what the media was doing
over the past few weeks I my second
quick question is as much as Elizabeth
hbu Miller has been rightly skewered for
saying it's a bit intimidating task
tough question to our commander and
cheese do you I guess being on the
campaign trail did you at any point kind
of have a type of sympathy for that
sentiment I guess the answer to the
second question is yeah i mean sure if
you're if you're you know it can be a
little intimidating to to talk to a
journalist but you know it certainly to
a candidate but that's your that's your
job you know okay i mean if you're not
there to do that what are you there to
do so you know that can that can't
possibly be something that that you
should feel sorry for her for her
anybody else about I mean I I when I
first got on and I was with Howard Dean
on his plane and there were a couple of
times when I was standing right in front
of me and I wanted to ask a question and
I didn't
you know and I felt really bad about
that but that was my first day on the on
the campaign trail and I had to get over
it and Elizabeth Boone Miller works in
the White House press corps if she's not
over it by then she shouldn't be there
you know I get in there the first part
of your question and why do you think it
is that journalist well I think what you
said about the cost of the covering the
campaign is a great point and is
something that isn't really looked at
gotta figure that they're these large
well-heeled institutional organizations
that are sending reporters out in the
road they are under such fierce attack
for showing any kind of bias you know
and for not being objective and for not
being fair that they're gonna snuff out
anything that hints of revealing a bias
or showing you know that opens up
themselves up to attack from the other
guy to the left you know so it becomes
this very safe thing you need to talk
about the horse race because that's the
thing you can talk about in polite
conversation and that's the thing in
which you can you know if you're just if
you are buttressing your story poll
numbers and with you know and with you
know getting the guy who explained it's
the strategy to you you know you're no
danger of committing any of the of the
great sins which is you know to reveal a
bias and to show that you might actually
think independently about this process
right you know this is perfect sort of
self-censoring organism you know that
just you know that keeps going you know
buttress by tons of money right and by
fear between the money and the fear it
really works well if you've got these
organizations that really pleased
themselves well right yeah the other
thing about it is that there's another
there's another mechanism in place I
don't know anybody over here read about
ever read about cults like ouch enrico
well they one of the things that almost
all cults do is they don't allow you to
sleep as much as you really want to
right you're always tired that exact
same dynamic is at work in the campaign
trail you never really get more than
four and a half hours of sleep and your
job is really really hard most of these
guys have really logistical II very
difficult jobs they have to file you
know X number of words every day and
they're always just
barely in time doing it so the idea that
they would have time to think about any
other aspect of it to them it's just
monstrous that they would have to have
that burden you know so they would never
even consider really thinking about it
for the most part what aren't you also
seen as a little bit of a [ __ ] because
you're not filing every day oh yeah
there does become this kind of macho
thing or you know this you know that
we're like these soldiers and we're out
there or firing you know we're filing
every day on the front lines oh yeah
absolutely i remember this great moment
where that happen when i was in orlando
right and it was like our third stop
that day and everybody else is in the
filing room filing and here i am the
total freaking loser sitting there
reading Sports Illustrated right because
I don't have to file that day and this
this guy from I guess Newsweek this
photographer comes up and he's like and
I'm eating by the way i'm all i'm also
eating it this is before i went on my
hunger strike it's like well I don't
know how your story is going to turn up
but at least you're getting fed you know
like you know the idea that I'm just
freeloading while everybody else is
really working i got that a lot you know
but anyway so yeah
well you mentioned that um that mat or a
Viking suit at one point I was wondering
if you could tell us exactly what the
Vikings suit consisted of as well as if
you previously owned the Viking suitor
if you bought it specifically to the
campaign no I used I used to have ice
use a gorilla suit like I used to this
is really my own personal weirdness I
aced it just if everything went wrong
you know it's like break glass in case
of emergency I figure there's always
some kind of story if you just cover
something in a gorilla suit you know I
mean like I mean it's at least
interesting right you know so i used to
use a gorilla suit I used to carry that
with me all the time and I tried that in
New Hampshire a lot i kept I kept
breaking out the gorilla suit when I was
really in you know having down times but
the gorilla suit was really hot is
anyone here ever worn a gorilla suit for
any length of time yeah this really it
doesn't breathe so it gets really stuffy
and I and then before one on the carry
trip I saw Mike in costume and I'm like
this thing really breeze it's got like
holes in the side it's a skirt you know
so I thought we were going to be and
we're going to be traveling in the South
but that would be better than having a
gorilla suit so that's why a Viking suit
but and then how did it work the day you
wore the Viking suit well again this was
again the problem was I had no story
will didn't know this at the time and so
it was going to break out the Vikings
food for that precisely that emergency
right but I also the additional factor
there was that I found out that the
carries press top press guide David
Moore house was the former deputy head
of the ONDCP which is the Office of
National Drug Control Policy so he was
actually the guy who invented the fried
egg ed said I never seen the fried egg
head you know this is your brain on
drugs yeah so I thought well the very
least I don't have a story but at the
very least I can eat a whole bunch of
acid and interview this guy in a Viking
suit you know and then and then right
it later and then that'll make him look
silly but actually in the end I was the
one who looks chilly he was like [ __ ] is
wrong with you and that's why I can see
it but so that's how that happened but
taking you sort of know that was gonna
happen yeah at that point I didn't
really I mean but I figured I had to try
something you guys were paying me all
this money say you know and that's
really what I was thinking at the time
like you know I away these guys to make
his big an ass of myself as I possibly
can yeah so well then you once right in
the Exile that you want it to be go down
as one of the great pain the ass kissing
in American history yeah but this
definitely wasn't working those who has
the biggest losers in American history
anyway it got you guys a microphone
how are you I s wondering what do the
candidate like Dennis Kucinich that
doesn't have a lot of money doesn't have
an experienced staff what could what
could he do to like in some traction in
the press but you know who seems to kind
of important that's a really difficult
question you know like what is somebody
and I wrote a lot about Dennis in this
book because I spent a lot of time with
him and I remember there was a really
interesting moment when I was asking
people on the Dean plane know why are we
all covering this horse race thing like
the word i think the horse horse race
thing like what does it actually do for
us this horse for his business I mean
what's the journalistic benefit to doing
that and no fewer than four people said
essentially the same thing they said
well you know we have to do to do that
so that people know why it is that we're
not that we're not covering somebody
like Dennis Kucinich we have we have to
focus in the candidate who can win
because otherwise it'll come down to a
battle of position papers and one guy
actually said that otherwise it'll come
down to a battle position papers and
somebody like Kucinich will win you know
and i'm like end you know but that's the
that's the answer it is that they they
have this preconceived notion of what
the front-runner looks like and and they
they look for that person and anytime
the candidate lacks those qualities they
will pester him about it and until until
he loses his mind like Dean did you know
he either has to mean I would guess that
he either have to have a lot of personal
magnetism need to have to have a gift
for dealing with what John McCain was
the one guy whoever broke through that
way right he basically just said I'm
gonna sit here and give this I'll give
the reporters everything of me they need
right and I'll just sit there and I'll
answer every question and I'll spend as
much time with them as possible and
impurity unguarded right and I and then
they broke him in South Carolina exactly
exactly but the press never quite turned
to the pressing really turned against
him right you know they became a lovable
loser right you know but uh I mean I
think cuz sinners probably didn't have
the personal magnetism and Emmy Kucinich
you know would allow him you know he
would act he would say weird things oh
yeah he's a weird guy question about it
I mean you know I mean I remember
interviewing Dennis once and he's eating
udon noodles in front of me and I'm
trying to do this interview with him
first of all and it was until the end of
the interview that we realized he
thought I was from the New York Times
I'm like em but he would it be
interviewing me and the noodles would be
little it would be hanging out of his
mouth as he's talking to me and I'm like
you know as much as I hate the horse
race thing you just can't have the udon
noodles in your mouth you know why
you're talking to visit huh get your
time exactly so but um yeah but you know
Dennis the thing that was really
interesting about him is that he
presented a great contrast with the way
their normal candidates work like the
reason I'm disappointed in the
candidates is because they know
something and they're not telling us you
know and John Kerry has been set set on
the most influential committees in the
Senate for how many with 20 years right
he knows the way the world really works
and he's not really telling he's not
telling when he gets up to give a speech
he's not telling you anything you
haven't heard of her before right
whereas I would sit down with Dennis
Kucinich you need today look this is the
way we do a bill on free trade this is
how it works you know it goes it goes
through the house it goes through the
Senate then when it goes into the joint
committee they add all this horrible
stuff in here because you know X
lobbyists you know told me to put it
told ex-congressman to put it in and
here's the sections that were added in
afterwards and you know in in in the
joint conference and he actually took
out you know the WTO bill and pointed
out all the horrible stuff that was in
was in the bill and you know that's what
that's what the candidates should be
doing you know and Dennis did that but
nobody was listening you know so it's
it's just too bad what do you think of
Dean I mean you were with him for quite
a while you know seeing him from being a
guy almost as marginal as Dennis
Kucinich was to being with you know
first perceived to be within striking
distance of the nomination did you see
him change or did you see what his
opinions evolve and adapt to the new
realities I guess you know I always
thought Dean kind of got a bit of a raw
deal because even though I don't kind of
have any personal feelings towards and
one way or the other but that was a
great instance of where you know he the
press had this idea of what the front
runner was going to be and somebody
decided early on the Dean was just he
was to the word they use was prickly but
he was too prickly to be President and
they would ask him that you know 20 or
30 times a date aren't you aren't you're
not warm enough to be President are you
not funny enough to be President aren't
you too prickly to be President and he'd
be like no no I'm cool you know and that
would be like the first you know four
months he was trying to be this no I'm
you know I'm really a nice guy and then
finally he's like why of course I'm
freaking prickly you know you're asking
me these questions you and then he you
know you ended up losing his mind and
that's that's what you know that's what
happened I think they really got to him
but you know personally I thought Dean
Dean was you know at least not he was a
smart guy anyway right I mean didn't you
think yeah but I he he just didn't have
that gift for for BS in with the the
press that I guess he needed to be to be
a front-runner
how about Wesley Clark cuz I think you
had a fascinating take on Wesley Clark
do you know that no one else really
picked up on I mean you called him you
know in your nation piece and it's which
is in the book and it's not in the book
figured out yeah why cuz I hated that
piece yeah I don't know Wesley Clark
yeah you know I wish I thought he was a
phony and and that he this is a guy who
would who had been an ardent supporter
of the Vietnam or that it actually when
he was he was living in London in the
60s you just used to take tours around
Europe campaigning in support of the
Vietnam War and this was the guy he was
like a pro Nixon guy back in the day and
suddenly he's the great great Democratic
Savior right against george bush and it
was just I thought it was really strange
the press didn't didn't go after him
about his past or about his you know his
militaristic viewpoints or anything like
that and but fortunately he his campaign
and bloated anyway
are there any other questions from
anyone in the audience well I will let
you two have a few minutes to wrap it up
then and then Matt will be signing books
at the front of the store okay excellent
well that's it thank you I guess thanks
very much for coming everybody yeah
thanks to my math book make you famous
thanks for coming oh you got another
question here wait wait wait wait well I
do have one book I have a previous book
out that's called the exile which has
some of that stuff but mostly mostly
know there's there's some stuff the book
that I publish is really about about the
newspaper and it didn't really have so
much of that stuff but most of us online
so you know still it's still on the XL
website thank you okay